had so many girls on this show tell me
that lizzo is like above a five which is
just
like crazy like it's lizzie
but every i think everyone's scale is
different at the end of the day what
your five is someone else
is i think objectively like if you're
300 pounds you're below 5.
that's your opinion though that's your
opinion i mean
that's your opinion but it's based off
of reality which women don't like to
live in because even this is like not
reality and you know it on some level
because you know if you walk into a bar
with lizzo you guys are all going to get
more attention than lizzo like do you
have anything
not necessarily like if you're looking
for exceptions it's not the rule like
you could take you could take you could
take dating app data where we like let's
like put your profile on lizzo's profile
who's going to get more attention it's
going to be you we could go into a
modeling a modeling agency and say who
are they going to sign you or lizzo in
general unless you do that victoria's
secret like you know
the new body positivity type [ __ ] i know
again again exceptions but whenever you
go anywhere where there's like an
objective standard of beauty where like
people are find this the most attractive
in general you're you guys are all
prettier than lizzo and that's not
that's my question is and i think yeah
you make some again interesting points
around like
it's really helpful to see that like i i
don't know if you guys always see like
the stats that come out from
certain dating apps don't know how to
say certain names but they they produce
these stuff right like who comes out as
the most desirable women my question
would be and modeling agencies and
modeling agencies yeah and by who's
beauty standards i was just going to say
that i mean i would say like
collectively society as a whole so if
you survey if you serve it if you survey
men and women as well and you if you
survey men and women as a whole in
general in most societies
they put in the most and most and most
societies throughout the world
everywhere ever i guarantee like just
just base that wait let me let me finish
in most societies throughout the world
everywhere if we put a picture of you
guys in a picture of lizzo if you ask
most guys and most girls they would find
you more attractive in west africa and
except yeah they always this is what
this is what girls do like sorry i've
been doing this couple months not you
personally but like like this is what
they'll do they'll bring up the one
exception and that one society in in
west africa you're right there's one
society in west africa where that is the
exception
but
everywhere else
that is the rule i think that's such a
eurocentric way of viewing beauty look
at the size of africa look at the size
of yours i won't even do all that i
won't even do all that i think what we
can also look at is just beauty
standards shift right like i was 10
years ago having a like a fat ass was
like okay you but nowadays it's like if
you don't have a fat ass you're not
attracted exactly
sorry it stays a while when there's a
standard set so
um let's say 10 years ago being a
supermodel model finn was in fashion it
will stay there for a little bit then
come another trend yeah it's not like it
just changes but but the point i'm
making is that
the issue that i'm having is and i agree
i agree with you it's weird i didn't
think i was going to disagree with you
as much as i'm doing today but um
when it comes down to that number of
like or you're five and below it's like
okay
ten years ago if i had a fat ass then
i'm i'm a five and below but i didn't
say 10 years ago i said today but i'm
just saying like it shifts so for you to
say like oh like i i'm not gonna comment
on lizzo but for you to say that so
definitively that if you're over this
you're that
i think that's what people have a hard
time dealing with and on top of that
it's like we connect that what's that
five me
do you think do you think in most of
human history okay one there probably
wasn't even women over 300 pounds in
most of human history but since since
the development of like obesity has
obesity ever been desired by and large
by men
by and large i can't call it but
i don't know come on just with your
common sense
just with your common sense i mean with
my common sense i want to say no but
that's that's what my body is right i
don't know what them just by by and
large i just think personally speaking
in london in terms of 2022 now what is
considered like a 10 is very different
like we said it was five years ago and
i'm not gonna lie being thick which is
um thick comes in all different shapes
and sizes it can go from somebody that
is let's say a size 12 but she's got
really thick thighs or a big bum or
something someone that's a size 18. it
is different i would say
i don't personally agree to say someone
that's over 300 pounds
would then be considered below a five i
i don't agree with that and i think a
lot of i'm gonna say
especially in london specifically
i don't think a lot of people are to sit
there and say that i mean i mean i think
sometimes like you have a warped world
view because um like the society is made
for women so like 70 to 80 of consumer
buying decisions are made um by women
and so you see the whole media is
tailored towards women so when you see
women in the media it's like pretty much
just to cater to women but the thing is
like the majority of the most desired
women if if they're thicker they have a
small waist it's always been the
hourglass but you get some women that
could be over 300 pounds and have a
small waist that happens have you seen
that i've definitely seen it
it's definitely enough yeah
okay but i'm saying you can see
you can see some girls that are maybe
let's say it's pretty pretty tall i know
what a size 18.
i'm in the top one percent of height if
i was 300 pounds no you're right but
i've been pleasantly surprised like
sometimes you'll ask a girl
i i wait i weigh more weight i i weigh
more i have a friend that's six five
yeah and we would weigh more than you
would expect exactly but i'm saying it's
300 no 300's pushing it 300 is
definitely pushing because yeah i don't
know what the ninja looks like on a guy
let alone no
but
i mean i always like to count a question
to ask all the ladies in the room
generally speaking would you be more
attracted to a man that's over six foot
or around that region there in
comparison to someone let's say my
height five foot seven
with with a good personality naturally
with your instincts what do you feel
you're selling yourself well i love it
hey listen
i will keep it real
i feel like we should be diplomatic i
feel like you haven't spoken that much
well personally i've never been
interested in height like it doesn't
bother me whether they're the same
height as me taller shorter whatever
like
i am much more of an emotional person
than i am sort of
that side of things that's not what i
initially go for it's like that
connection with a person i don't care
whether they're taller than me or not or
whether they've got you know a dad board
or a six-pack like
that aesthetic side of it isn't
important obviously you've got to have
an attraction to somebody to want to be
with them
but i don't think
i would necessarily go for somebody
who's got those norms if they do they do
but that's not what i intentionally look
for
yeah
yeah no i literally yeah did you guys
date a guy three inches shorter than you
yes yeah
who said no me okay at least you're
honest i think i'm just no i haven't i'm
being dead um i would date somebody
who's the same height as me but
personally i would just feel like um
you see if i wear heels i understand
like there is that element but i would
overall like to be with a man that's at
least the same height as me or taller
because it just makes me feel like
i don't know if i think it's more
masculine i'm just attracted to that
um personally
um and i've had like the best connection
with someone and you honestly were like
this person is my soulmate like i
i have i can get on with them better
than anyone else and i generally want to
you know spend the rest of my life with
them whatever but then you go oh
actually
he's a few inches shorter than me i'm
just being realistic because you see i'm
i'm not necessarily like a man like a
visual creature but you know the first
thing you look at is actually looks so
even if let's say you're not my usual
type or there is something about you
that's you know like oh you're not my
perfect type i feel like there needs to
be that sort of attraction and if
there's no attraction between me and
that person i would just see them more
as a friend per se and that's just
me personally
no i do agree with you in that sense
like in terms of your original question
would i date a guy that's your high or
not the same height as me yes i would if
someone was three inches shorter than me
no i wouldn't mainly because i